imagine we take an image and add a bit
of gaussian noise to it
then do this again
if we repeat this enough times
eventually we'll have an unrecognizable
picture of static a sample of pure noise
now what if we could figure out how to
undo this process
that is start from a noise image
gradually remove the noise and end up
with a coherent image
this is the basic idea behind diffusion
models an approach gaining traction and
generative modeling it had success
particularly in the domain of image
generation and they are starting to
rival and in some cases surpass other
kinds of generative models you may be
familiar with on certain tasks
for example recent diffusion models have
outperformed generative adversarial
networks known as gans in perceptual
quality metrics and they've also shown
impressive performance in various
conditional settings such as converting
text descriptions to images
in painting
and manipulation
in this video we'll try to understand
the basic mechanism behind diffusion
models and how they can be adapted to
different generative settings
we'll start with a sample from some
target data distribution like an image
from a training set
let's call this x0
now let's define a forward diffusion
process that gradually adds noise to the
image over big t time steps
our model will be tasked with starting
at x big t and undoing this noise
through what we'll call the reverse
process
the forward process which we'll denote
with q takes the form of a markov chain
where the distribution at a particular
time step only depends on the sample
from the immediately previous step
so we can write out the distribution of
corrupted samples conditioned on the
initial data point x0 as the product of
successive single step conditionals
in the case of continuous data each
transition is parameterized as a
diagonal gaussian
beta t here is the variance at a
particular time step t
typically these variances are treated as
hyperparameters and follow a fixed
schedule for a particular training run
beta generally increases with time and
is restricted to be between zero and one
meaning that this coefficient radical
one minus beta t
will likewise be non-zero but less than
one bringing the mean of each new
gaussian closer to zero
in the limit as t approaches infinity
q will approach a gaussian centered at
zero with identity covariance losing all
information about the original sample
in practice the total number of steps
big t is on the order of a thousand
using a large albeit finite number of
steps allows us to set the individual
variances beta t to be very small while
still approximately maintaining the same
limiting distribution
but why do we want to use a small step
size what's the benefit
well it means that learning to undo the
steps of the forward process won't be
too difficult
let's consider a simple case in one
dimension
suppose we were given the distribution
of a forward process sample at time t
minus one and it resembled a mixture of
gaussians with two modes
we then observe x t
and want to infer the posterior
distribution over x t minus one
that is we'd like to determine where did
the chain likely come from in order to
arrive at x t
what was the previous step of the chain
if the noise step that is q of x t given
x t minus 1 is allowed to be large then
we will be quite uncertain about the
location of x t minus 1. who knows where
we jumped from
but if the forward noise step is
restricted to be small there is much
less ambiguity about x t minus 1.
we could then be justified in modeling
the posterior of the forward step that
is q of x t minus 1 given x t
with a unimodal gaussian
eliminating the contribution from the
mode to the right
and in fact it can be shown
theoretically that in the limit of
infinitesimal step sizes the true
reverse process will have the same
functional form as the forward process
so diffusion models leverage this
observation parameterizing each learned
reverse step to also be a unimodal
diagonal gaussian
aside from the sample at time t the
model also takes t as input in order to
account for the forward process variance
schedule different time steps are
associated with different noise levels
and the model can learn to undo these
individually
like the forward process the reverse
process is set up as a markov chain
and we can write out the joint
probability of a sequence of samples as
a product of conditionals and the
marginal probability of x big t
so what is p of x big t here exactly
well it's the same as q of x big t the
pure noise distribution
so at inference time in order to
actually generate a sample we start from
a gaussian and begin sampling from the
learned individual steps of the reverse
process p of x t minus 1 given x t until
producing an x0
okay great so we've defined these
forward and reverse diffusion processes
the forward process is designed to
essentially push a sample off the data
manifold turning it into noise and the
reverse process is trained to produce a
trajectory back to the data manifold
resulting in a reasonable sample
but what objective will we actually be
optimizing is it some maximum likelihood
objective where we directly maximize the
density assigned to x0 by the model
well not exactly
if we try to calculate p of x0 we see
that we have to marginalize over all the
possible trajectories all the ways we
could have arrived at x0 when starting
from a noise sample
this unfortunately is intractable
but it turns out we can maximize a lower
bound
to do this let's view x1 through x big t
as latent variables and x0 as an
observed variable
allowing us to interpret a diffusion
model as a kind of latent variable
generative model
if we think back to another latent
variable model you may be familiar with
variational autoencoders commonly known
as vaes
we might get a hint about our training
objective
as a quick reminder in a vae we have an
encoder that produces a distribution
over latency given a data input x
and a decoder that reconstructs the data
by producing a distribution over data x
given a latent input z
so we can think of the forward process
in diffusion models as analogous to the
encoder producing latency from data
and the reverse process as analogous to
the decoder producing data from latents
now unlike a vae encoder the forward
process here is typically fixed
it's the reverse process that we focus
solely on learning
this means that only a single network
needs to be trained unlike in a vae
where two networks are trained jointly
so we can now borrow the basic training
objective used by vaes and a number of
other latent variable models
when we have a model with observations x
and latent variable z
we can derive what's called the
variational lower bound also known as
the evidence lower bound
a lower bound on the marginal log
likelihood p theta of x
we won't walk through the full
derivation here but the end result is a
likelihood term also known as a
reconstruction term subtracted by a kl
divergence term
the likelihood term encourages the model
to maximize the expected density
assigned to the data
while the kl divergence encourages the
approximate posterior q z given x to be
similar to the prior on the latent
variable p of z
as we saw earlier x0 will serve as the
observation in the diffusion model
framework while x1 through big t will
take the place of the latent variable z
here
let's substitute these in
alright now let's simplify a bit
we can expand the kl divergence to
combine the two terms into a single
expectation
and finally we can refactor the chain
probabilities into their individual
steps
now there's a nice property of the
forward process queue that we didn't
touch on earlier any arbitrary step of
the forward process can be sampled
directly in closed form
this is just because the sum of
independent gaussian steps is still a
gaussian
so at training time any term of this
objective can be obtained without having
to simulate an entire chain
likewise we can optimize this objective
by randomly sampling pairs of x t minus
one and x t
and maximizing the conditional density
assigned by the reverse step to x t
minus one
however because different trajectories
may visit different samples at time t
minus one on the way to hitting xt
the setup can have high variance
limiting training efficiency
to help with this we can rearrange the
objective as follows
let's examine each component
p of x big t is fixed it's just the
start of the reverse process the pure
noise distribution
and as we saw earlier the whole forward
process q is also treated as fixed
so we just have to worry about these two
terms to the right
here we have a sum of kl divergences
each between a reverse step and a
forward process posterior conditioned on
x0
one can prove with bayes rule that when
we treat the original sample x0 as known
like it is during training these q terms
are actually just gaussians
since the reverse step is already
parameterized as a gaussian each kl
divergence now is simply comparing two
gaussians and can be evaluated in closed
form
this helps reduce variance in the
training process because instead of
aiming to reconstruct monte carlo
samples
the targets for the reverse step become
the true posteriors of the forward
process given x0
there are a couple different ways we
could imagine implementing the reverse
step p theta in the paper denoising
diffusion probabilistic models
ddpm for short
the authors elect to set the reverse
process variances to time specific
constants as they found learning them to
lead to unstable training and lower
quality samples
so the reverse step network is solely
tasked with learning the means
they then suggest a reparameterization
that aims to have the network predict
the noise that was added rather than the
gaussian mean
first we can rewrite sampling from an
arbitrary forward step by using an
auxiliary noise variable epsilon
epsilon here has a constant distribution
independent of the forward time step t
and the reverse step model can be
designed to simply predict this epsilon
the authors also found that a simpler
version of the variational bound that
discards the term weights that appear in
the original bound led to better sample
quality
so compared to the original variational
lower bound their objective down weight
steps that have very small noise at
early time steps of the forward process
allowing training to focus on more
challenging greater noise steps
like other generative frameworks
diffusion models can be made to sample
conditionally given some variable of
interest like a class label or a
sentence description
one way to do this is to just feed the
conditioning variable y as an additional
input during training
in theory the model should learn to use
y as a helpful hint about what it should
be reconstructing in practice some work
has shown that further guiding the
diffusion process with a separate
classifier can help
in this setup we take a trained
classifier and push the reverse
diffusion process in the direction of
the gradient of the target label
probability with respect to the current
noise image
and we can do this not just with single
word labels but also with higher
dimensional text descriptions as well
of course one drawback of this technique
is the reliance upon a second network
an alternative approach eliminates this
reliance instead using special training
of the diffusion model itself to guide
the sampling
in the paper classifier free diffusion
guidance the conditioning label y is set
to a null label with some probability
during training
then at inference time the reconstructed
samples are artificially pushed further
towards the y conditional direction and
away from the null label
even though no new information is being
given to the model they found this to
produce higher quality samples under
human evaluation compared to classifier
guidance
inpainting is another conditional
generation problem where diffusion
models have had success
the naive way to perform in-painting
with diffusion models is to take a model
trained in the standard way and at
inference time replace known regions of
an image with a sample from the forward
process after each reverse step
now this works okay but can lead to edge
artifacts
the model is not being made aware of the
full surrounding context only a hazy
version of it
instead better results come from
fine-tuning a model specifically for
this task
we can randomly remove sections of
training images and have the model
attempt to fill them in conditioned on
the full clear context
we can compare diffusion models to some
other prominent degenerative models
for sampling tasks the fusion models are
somewhat limited by the slow markov
chain
this contrasts for example with gans
which can generate images in a single
forward pass
ongoing work aims to speed up sampling
in diffusion models
as we saw earlier diffusion models allow
us to calculate a variational lower
bound on the log likelihood similar to
vaes
in practice this lower bound can be
quite good and even competitive on
density estimation benchmarks which have
long been dominated by auto aggressive
models
going beyond lower bounds a continuous
time formulation of diffusion models can
give rise to what's called a probability
flow ode
this enables approximating log
likelihood via numerical integration
there's a close connection between
denoising diffusion models and what are
called score matching models and often
these are now grouped together into a
single class of models score here refers
to the gradient of the log of the target
probability density with respect to the
data
a score network is trained to estimate
this value
then a markov chain is set up to
actually produce samples from the learn
distribution
guided by this gradient
well it turns out the score can actually
be shown to be equivalent to the noise
that's predicted in the denoising
diffusion objective up to a scaling
factor
so we can think of undoing the noise in
a diffusion model approximately as
trying to follow the gradient of the
data log density
diffusion models are really gaining
momentum and it's been exciting to see
their progress
check out the links in the description
to learn more
thanks for watching